mariana se dejará su cumpleaños con un
paseo su mamá le pidió que eligiera dos
lugares a donde desea ir siempre y
cuando no estén a más de un kilómetro de
distancia de su casa ya que más tarde
partirá un pastel con sus primos como
mariana desconoce qué tan lejos están
los lugares que desea visitar su papá le
dio un mapa de la zona en donde vive
revisemos el mapa de frente
tenemos una escala y los cuatro puntos
cardinales norte sur este y oeste
ubicamos la casa de mariana está justo
aquí
es adquirir a todos estos lugares al
cine al parque a una granja y a un
restaurante vamos a ubicar estos lugares
en el mapa y después utilizaremos la
escala para determinar qué tan lejos
quedan de su casa ok
el cine está hacia el sur es este de
aquí el parque está hacia el oeste nos
faltan la granja y el restaurante ya los
vi el restaurante está cerca del estadio
de fútbol y la granja hacia el norte
listo aquí la tenemos
para medir la distancia de la casa de
mariana a los lugares que quiere visitar
utilizaremos la escala del mapa donde un
centímetro equivale a 100 metros
comencemos por la granja iremos por esta
avenida para llegar directamente ahora
dividiremos esta ruta en centímetros
como los que marca la escala entonces
aquí sería 12
4 5 6 7 y 8 centímetros como cada
centímetro equivale a 100 metros
entonces serían 800 metros de la casa de
mariana a la granja vayamos al
restaurante cómo está el sur bajamos por
aquí entramos por la avenida y llegamos
utilizamos la escala contemos 1 2
4 5 6 7 y 8 centímetros es decir serían
800 metros
ahora la distancia hacia el cine
este ya no está muy lejos del
restaurante así que podemos tomar parte
de la ruta anterior y solo agregaremos
los metros que faltan para llegar al
cine
si contamos a partir del restaurante
serían 12
y 7 que es igual a 700 metros
entonces sumando estos 700 a los 800
metros que hay de la casa de mariana al
restaurante dan un total de 1500 metros
lo que es igual a un kilómetro y medio
por último midamos la distancia hacia el
parque si vamos por la avenida clave les
damos vuelta a la izquierda para bajar
por avenida tulipanes y así llegaremos
al parque ahora a medir 12
7 8 9 10 y 11 que serían 1.100 metros o
un kilómetro con 100 metros
solo falta comparar las distancias para
que mariana pueda decidir cuáles son los
lugares a los que puede ir de la casa de
mariana la granja son 800 metros después
tenemos el restaurante que son 800
metros al cine son 1500 metros y
finalmente al parque son 1.100 metros
perfecto los lugares más cercanos a su
casa son la granja y el restaurante como
observaste el uso de escalas en los
mapas facilita el cálculo de distancias
de un punto a otro y nos apoya para
poder tomar algunas decisiones como lo
hizo mariana sigue practicando